it's great to have back on the program
today will summer who's a politics
reporter for The Daily Beast and also
co-host of the fever dreams podcast
about conservative media he's author of
the book trust the plan the rise of Q
Anon and the conspiracy that unhinged
America will great to have you back
David thanks for having me so you know
we many of us have seen the polls that
came out over the last couple years some
which will make claims like you know a
fifth of Americans or of Republicans or
whoever believe some aspect of Q Anon
beliefs and then you know you look more
deeply and sometimes it's the slightly
less crazy beliefs and so it can be sort
of hard to know like what does it really
mean when we say this portion of the
population believes this stuff and are
some of these beliefs unique to Q Anon
or are they kind of coincidental so
let's just maybe start with what is your
understanding right now of when we talk
about Q Anon conspiracies with which
conspiracies are we talking about sure
so yeah I mean I think it might be
helpful there to sort of lay down the
the fundamental belief of Q Anon and
then you know we can go from there yeah
so I would say you know it there's so
much crazy stuff involved in this but
but I think kind of the core belief is
that the world is run by a cabal of
pedophile satanists who torture children
in Satanic rituals to drink their blood
um and that this includes people in
banking in Hollywood and the Democratic
party so that's and the the second part
of that is that this moment is going to
come called the storm where Donald Trump
is gonna essentially impose a fact
fascist dictatorship on America but they
think that's a great idea right and
execute his enemies and so I would say
that's sort of the core belief of Q Anon
so when we when people are polled on do
you think that world Elites are in
satanic uh Cults and you know abusing
children that's in the typical in the
the teens to the the low 20
um when you ask people uh do you believe
in q on straight up it's usually and and
you know I like to go with the most
conservative estimates here because as
you say I mean when we make it really
broad if we say do you think powerful
people abuse children sometimes you know
the answer is you know that's not an
unreasonable thing to believe um so when
you ask people do you believe in Q Anon
really kind of flat out they typically
say three to seven percent
um and so you know I like to go with the
that kind of stricter definition but at
the same time when you say you know talk
about satanic Cults more generally
that's still a lot of people right and
that's that's pretty crazy belief so
even on on the lower end we're talking
about millions of Americans
um a lot of the the way you just laid it
out
there are lots of similar conspiracy
theories by substituting just like one
word like for example the storm sounds
surprisingly similar to the Christian
Rapture that some believe in but just
with like slightly different details and
then the premise of the satanic
pedophiles are the cabal sounds very
similar to sort of like it's Jews who
are the ones in control how how much is
this a recycling of other versions of
these tropes and how much of it is
unique
sure I mean I I think it's a blend I
think Q Anon plays on these
centuries-old tropes for example in the
book I talk about how so much of Q Anon
I mean I mentioned the blood drinking
right uh you know that is a direct play
on this idea of the Jewish blood libel
this idea of dating back to the 13th
century that Jewish people were
murdering children to get blood to make
matzo bread for uh for Passover
um and that's everybody knows it's just
wheat and water that's the beauty of it
you know why would you adulterate it
with blood well who would do that
exactly
um and so but you know this idea has set
off all these pogroms and all these
murders
um and so it researches in Q Anon where
you know I think it's not accidental
that so many of the villains are Jewish
people in banking or the Democratic
party or Hollywood
um at the same time I think there are
some new elements such as this idea of
this kind of mysterious clue Giver cue
and this way that it it repackages so
many old conspiracy theories but in a
way that that feels fresh to people and
with with the concept of the storm gives
them something to look forward to so
it's not just you know kind of mulling
over all this sad stuff but it gives
them this kind of Twisted Utopia that
they can help bring about is there what
is your belief now as to whether there
is a person that is q
sure so I think
um it's never been conclusively proven
but I think the best argument we've seen
for who's behind q and I should say all
the people I'm going to name have denied
it yeah but that it is laid out pretty
effectively in the HBO docu-series cue
into the storm laying out that there was
sort of a random guy interested in
conspiracy theories who started it and
then it was hijacked from him by the
people who ran eight-chan uh his father
and son Duo uh Jim and Ron Watkins yeah
and you know in that series they there's
like a quasi-confession from Ron Watkins
but no one has ever come out and said
yes I'm q but I think absent any other
evidence uh that's we can pretty much
assume I I think it's fair to say that
it's those two yeah Ron Watkins ran for
was it governor of Arizona or was it a
member of Congress I don't remember it
was a much more modest goalie he only
thought he could be a member of the
House member of the house right and uh I
mean one of the uh creepiest uh auras
surrounding that guy of anyone I can
think of
um and I don't think that the cue thing
came up during the race did it or now
I'm not sure uh not in a major way I
mean really we need to clear it in this
primary
um it was and you know he had been
living in Japan for a while this is a
very kind of bizarre thing he didn't
even live in the district at the time or
he had just moved there and I think he
had had this brief uh separate career
apart from Human as like an election
fraud expert after Trump lost right I
think he thought he thought you know
maybe I've been on one America news a
couple times now I can run for the house
and I talked to all these guys in
Arizona these political operatives and
they said you know no way this guy's
gonna get slaughtered and as it turned
out he did yeah
um when we hear sometimes we'll like
send a correspondent to Trump rallies we
have this guy Luke Beasley who's who's
been going and and so on and he'll talk
to people and very often people won't
bring up anything about Q or Q Anon but
they will say things like uh the current
president is actually Trump who's
controlling the military or a JFK is
alive and sometimes you can tell they
don't know the difference between
between JFK Senior and Junior and
they're like oh well one of them would
be a hundred and but it's it's all
they're all very confused and you don't
know where they got this stuff are when
you hear people say that stuff
is that connected to cue beliefs in some
way yeah absolutely I mean I think the
key thing for people to understand now
that we look and we say oh you know I
don't hear about cunan that much there
aren't too many people like out and
about with cute on shirts at the end of
2020 Q told his followers to stop saying
they were part of Q Anon I think the
sense was that the brand had been
damaged and so instead to spread these Q
anon-like ideas about the cabal JFK Jr
all these different things yeah but just
don't say hey would you like to learn
about Q Anon because you know and so now
even now I have people say oh you know
there's no Q Anon there is q and there
are the anions I mean it it's these kind
of linguistic tricks they use yeah but
but I think even for people who have
never seen Q Clues this kind of stuff I
think these ideas have become
mainstreamed in the in the excuse me
mainstreamed in the Republican party and
you know a great way to see that is
going to these Trump rallies in these
events because whether it's y'all uh
Someone Like Jordan klepper on The Daily
Show you kind of just tap a little bit
and they say well I don't like the
corruption yeah I don't mean by the
corruption they say well let me tell you
about pizza gate right right no we've
seen we've seen that develop in real
time it's often under 60 seconds you go
from some benign comment to really
really wacky wacky stuff
um Marjorie Taylor green had this moment
um around the time that Republicans took
over the house and she made it clear she
wants to kind of be on the inside now
and sided with Kevin McCarthy in the
speaker battle where she very kind of
generically said I fell for some stuff
on the internet and it's happened to a
lot of us and it was interpreted that
that was a reference to some of the Q
Anon type stuff that in 2018 she seemed
to be kind of pushing and following
um what what's your sense of that change
that we're seeing in people like green
and bobert and others with relation to
their association with Q Anon stuff yeah
so in the book I get into it I mean I
think it there's varying degrees of Q
Anon devotion on one hand you have
Lauren bobert who as far as we know
simply saw it as sort of a cynical thing
to nod at and flirt with and say well q
and on they got some interesting points
but maybe it's not for me Marshall
Taylor green on the other hand I would
put in like the top one or two percent
of Q Anon commitment when you read her
old posts I mean she was she knows more
about Q Anon than I do I wrote a book
about it right I mean she was like
getting into these kind of talmudic
debates about you know the origins of
different cue drops and saying well this
is a fake one this is a real one I mean
she was deep deep in it and so now when
she comes out and says oh I guess I I
retweeted the wrong YouTube video or
what have you I mean that is just not
true when it comes to 2024
and we have Trump as a nominee and I
think that there are some in the media
that are overstating the competitiveness
of the primary if you look at the recent
polls something has to really change for
Trump to fall out of favor
um and and that could happen it could
have but but I do think that it's not
quite as competitive as some might like
it to be if we see Trump on the path
towards the 2024 nomination do you
expect to see the Q Anon Resurgence that
we saw in previous years or does it seem
like maybe Maga has to a degree move
Beyond it
I think we're going to see I think
there's a good chance that we'll see Q
Anon come back um in a more visible way
I mean it's kind of been bubbling online
and and it's gaining on foothold again
now that you know elon's letting them
back on Twitter and all these things oh
yeah um but but I do think I mean Trump
is he's signaling to Q Anon constantly I
mean there was one study that said a
third of his posts on Truth social have
been promoting Q Anon uh you know I
either because he'll just he does it now
in a way that he never did during the
campaign where he would he'll just post
memes of himself wearing a like edited
to have a Q Anon button and stuff I mean
he's really out there with it uh and you
know now he's implying that Ron DeSantis
is a pedophile he's posting these
pictures of him partying with high
school students saying could this be our
you know our beloved Ron
um and and you know I I'll just say
David I mean this is the idea that this
is not going to be a competitive primary
I'm with you I mean something could
change but people just you gotta watch
Ron DeSantis talk and you think I mean
this guy's gonna go up against Trump I
don't think so that's interesting let's
talk about that a little bit you cover
these these issues as well I understand
you you haven't announced and you've got
30 40 percent in some polls that that's
pretty remarkable stuff I mean there's
nobody's going to deny that the question
is by announcing do you take any of
Trump's support or is it going to be a
consolidation of the existing non-trump
electorate and I think it's it's sort of
the latter
um and when I think about the complete
lack of Charisma that DeSantis has and
he sort of expressed the desire to go
high and not stoop to Trump's level
which is fine in some general you know
vague vague sense but practically
speaking I don't think it's going to
work the numbers in his favor if that's
the way the primary goes I think Trump
will just crush him yeah I mean you see
these and these are all anecdotal things
but you know there was recently that
clip on Fox News which we know is trying
to favor DeSantis yeah where Brian
Kilmeade is in a diner saying well you
know primary is coming up and he just
say it's here and everyone goes Trump
Trump trump you know
and you know he's gonna have to campaign
at some point I think he's kind of
awkward enough that they're going to try
to keep him from doing much retail
campaigning but there's going to be some
video where he just looks weird and I
mean and then Trump's just gonna say you
know look at meatball Ron yeah and by
the way not I couldn't care less about
this but it's wild that in the midst of
all of the anti-drag stuff
DeSantis seems to regularly wear like
high-heeled cowboy boots which I know is
a whole thing and like I it doesn't
bother me it's just interesting how they
fall into these weird things where it
seems like is that going to help you
knowing what the kind of dialogue is
right now with some of these issues
among the people who support Trump to
begin with it all seems awkward
it it does seem awkward you know I mean
there's also that picture of you know
Biden's hugging people and DeSantis is
kind of stomping by yeah I mean it is I
think basically what's going on is I
think the conservative intellectuals and
media are smart enough to realize that I
think this answers would be a more
effective and potentially more vicious
Trump right I mean if we just see the
policies he's doing are very orban-esque
oh yeah you know he has all these
conservative intellectuals and I use
that term lightly like Chris Ruffo all
right he's you know he's a he's making
University trustees and stuff to really
like kind of crack the whip on these
liberal institutions uh whereas Trump
you know if he's president he'll be
stewing over Grayden Carter again you
know getting in his own way so I think
they want to do it but uh it seems
there's no evidence I think the
Grassroots wants to move on no I think
that that's uh that that's absolutely
the case uh the book is trust the plan
the rise of Q Anon and the conspiracy
that unhinged America we've been
speaking with the book's author will
summer who's also a politics reporter
for The Daily Beast and co-hosts the
fever dreams podcast
a will always great speaking to you
really appreciate it David thanks for
having me